mesurer l'efficacité des batteries
surveiller la température des circuits
pour éviter les surchauffes les
étudiants du groupe
helikos de polytechnique en sont aux
derniers préparatifs
il quitte montréal à destination
d'atlanta pour la deuxième année d'une
mission durant laquelle ils devront
repousser les limites de la science et
de la robotique aériennes les
compétitions ken auxquelles on participe
c'est tout en les compressant qui sont
impossibles avec l'attak tai ji quan
leur mission dotée un drone d'une
intelligence artificielle
le rebond doit non seulement décoller
voler et atterrir par lui-même
il devra aussi être en mesure de
localiser des petits robots aspirateurs
qui circulent au sol puis à la manière
d'un chien berger le drone devra
rassembler les robots aspirateurs de la
bonne couleur dans un enclos délimité
par une ligne au sol tout cela sans
assistance humaine
nous on n'intervient d'aucune manière
d'un clan qu'est-ce qui fait et non
seulement ça il ya aucun et aucun
comportement préprogrammés nous on
question dance et des engrais de
décision donc l'ups réagira qu'est ce
qui se passe en temps réel comme si ce
n'était pas suffisant
les organisateurs de la compétition
ajoute une longue liste de contraintes
comme l'interdiction de munir le drone
gps
on appellera t par rapport aux mains
auparavant plafond qu'on aime beaucoup
de contre 1 par rapport à la compétition
c'est le grand défi de comment voler de
façon autonome sans vraiment savoir
correspondait pour se repérer le
logiciel doit permettre aux rondes
identifier des points de repère au sol
sinon quelqu'un qui sont vraiment là le
verrez le stade olympique
mais si c'est que le stade est toujours
à sa droite mais dépendant de la
distance de lui pizzol un autre point du
don seront grands quartiers il va
pouvoir savoir où lui y est donc nous on
fait le même processus
mais avait clairement des points d'eau
qui serait plus simplement la
délimitation entre l'état qui est le
seul où le plancher se prêtent un bon
point pour de bon on a mis une femme et
un vers le sol qui évalue le déplacement
à hull et en ce sens le plus
quelques rires une hôtesse de la
compétition se déroule sur plusieurs
années l'an dernier le drone daily kos a
démontré qu'il pouvait voler de façon
autonome
ça nous a permis d'en savoir un peu
comme ça tellement d'aspects à prendre
en compte
l'équipe travaille maintenant pour que
le drone puisse localiser les robots
aspirateurs l'entraînement se fait
d'abord sur des cibles immobile le drone
doit apprendre à reconnaître la forme et
la couleur
on y voit encore avec elle les caméras
les rebonds des cas effectifs de couleur
sur lesquelles on va se baser
donc on va aller chercher la couleur
finalement de notre beau une fois qu'on
l'a localisé dans notre image mais là on
va aller au travail processus
décisionnel finalement de dire quel
robot et dont le propriétaire actuel est
quelquefois interrogé pour une deuxième
année de suite le robot volant daily kos
a impressionné les juges les étudiants
de polytechnique rentrer à nouveau
d'atlanta avec le titre de meilleure
équipe en amérique du nord
ici pas sa maison neuve radio canada
montréal